le calendrier des travaux de la ligne 18
c'est l'objet de la question posée au
préfet par le conseiller départemental
olivier de la fère et le représentant de
l'état dans les yvelines a rappelé les
concertations en cours sur ce dossier
suite bilan avant la meilleure façon de
ne pas traiter un problème c'est d'être
on passe du groupe de travail c'est ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui alors que les
choses sont claires
cette ligne 18 ans a besoin alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya de 1024 légion mais il
n'ya pas que ça il ya pour aussi arriver
à trouver des solutions nouvelles de
transports pour les personnes qui
travaillaient sur saint quentin
pierre bédier président du conseil
départemental est impliqué sur le
dossier
il a été reçu mardi 6 février au
ministère des transports on nous a
présenté trois calendriers différents
donc c'était assez assez surprenant le
tracé sur me confirmer le calendrier les
beaucoup moins et donc on aimerait bien
en savoir plus pierre bédier a demandé
qu'une étude soit faite pour qu'on sache
exactement les coûts et la date
d'activité de mise en activité de du
chantier ouais c'est ça qui nous
interpellent et qui nous inquiète
une inquiétude due aux problématiques
autour du calendrier prévu pour 2024
l'ouverture de la ligne 18 sur la partie
yvelinoise pourrait finalement être
retardé